to everyone who's been screaming for me
to review this movie I told you patience
is a virtue the Black Swan so the Black
Swan stars my wife Natalie Portman a
really nice really sweet perfectionist
type ballet dancer who's given the role
of a lifetime as she's given the role of
the Swan queen but she has to be both
White Swan who pretty much is what she
is naturally and Black Swan which is
everything she is absolutely not
but somewhere deep inside Natalie
Portman's character you can see the
spark of the devious and evil black
swans in there somewhere and what makes
it really cool is that all of us really
have that in us I mean not a swan
persona per se really yeah sounds really
yay you know what I mean all right we
all have good and evil moving on but
becoming the role of the Black Swan does
not come naturally to Natalie Portman's
characters she has to dig deep and that
makes with her perfectionist personality
we're in for some intense [ __ ] it gets a
little intense
now even though this movie ultimately
features ballet dancers everyone can
relate to it for two reasons one because
like I said we all have the contrast of
good and bad black and white and too
because we all know what it means to
want something just really badly I hope
we all know what that feels like anyway
and as for Mila Kunis in the movie she's
kind of Natalie Portman's opposite side
she's like the real-life Black Swan in
the movie the Black Swan role would be
as easy for her as the white swan role
is for Natalie Portman and I personally
really liked movies with that kind of
character contrast and Mila Kunis played
the role really well I mean just in the
way she walked talked moved interacted
she was cool fun sexy know the little
things that makes chick's hot Natalie
Portman and Mila Kunis in this movie
were like Batman in the Joker you know
one's chaos in one's order both could
probably learn a little from the other
but who are we kidding chaos a little
more fun when the two start knocking
back the drinks you get to see all sorts
of stuff you did not think you were
gonna see when you were watching attack
of the clones I mean well you thought
about it I thought about it many times
but I just didn't think I'd actually you
know see it but god bless you darren
aronofsky god bless you okay so was the
Black Swan good yes it was actually
really well done I mean it's well
written well directed Darren Aronofsky
has a way of delivering a really dark
and extreme vision of human beings and
making it surprisingly relatable if that
makes sense
a lot of crazy
[ __ ] happens in this movie it's
interesting it's creepy when human
beings start to crack it's not fun for
him and yes Natalie Portman she will
probably get an Oscar for this but let's
face it when we were watching Attack of
the Clones and she was like I truly
deeply love you we were all like I think
she's a little better than that I'm not
gonna live we're gonna blame that line
on the director cuz that was [ __ ]
she I think she's got more and we were
right so it was dark twisted creepy and
surprisingly relatable I probably
shouldn't relate to this movie but I
kind of knew that make me crazy so I
would say the Black Swan is oscar-worthy
and by that I mean well shot well acted
well directed memorable and effing
creepy it's a Georgian but I suppose
that's good
be it a bit artsy I mean is the Black
Swan my favorite movie of the year no
it's not because let's be honest I will
never go to my friends and be like dude
you know what I'm thinking let's have a
[ __ ] Black Swan night dude right now
Black Swan on blu-ray in my generic
blu-ray box this [ __ ] has to happen man
Black Swan night replay value plays into
it I'm just I'm not going to do that but
I am glad I saw it if you like really
dark psychological movies of
self-destruction you should probably see
it at least once and there is a Mila
Kunis Natalie Portman lesbo scene are
you still on the fence
cuz you really shouldn't be not now but
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more than click right here
to see more